Hey everybody.
What's up people?
Thank you for permitting us
to once again infect you
with a potent new strain of roll-on.
Wherein myself and my sidecar hype beast
the always congenial and ponderous,
Sir Adam Skolnick chew on matters of the day
withdrawal repertoire in a manner
that is hopefully somewhat instructive
and possibly at times even entertaining.
You're entertaining.
You getting fan mail now.
I just try to develop a rapport
with whoever I'm talking to.
You do, you're in communion with the audience.
I try to build rapport.
Well, as always, you guys know we do.
We talk about matters of the day.
We do a little bit of show and tell.
We answer listener questions
on the backend of the program.
If you would like your question considered
leave us a voicemail at (424) 235-4626.
Before we dive in my kids
who are my YouTube mentors tell me
that I must demand you indulge us
with a powerful smash
of that subscribe button on YouTube.
Okay Boomer, Apple podcast, Spotify
click that YouTube notification bell,
hit the thumbs up like button.
Leave your thoughts in the comment section below.
And that's it.
Let's get into it, Adam, how you doing?
Happy Passover.
Thank you, sir.
Happy half pass over to you.
Half passover?
Don't you have some-
No I'm an honorary.
Oh, you're honorary.
I'm not half.
Honorary passover(crosstalk).
You know, what's funny about Passover is that,
back in the day, well today actually.
Back in the day, like way back in the day?
Well like yesterday.
The day.
You could actually walk
from Egypt to Jerusalem in under a week
or the iron crab could probably do it in five days.
But back in the day when it was just a caravan
of opinionated Jews with no ways wrong turn, left turn,
right turn 40 years later,
they wind up in Jerusalem.
A lot of squabbling about which way to go.
It took a long time.
Is it really, you could do it in seven days?
Now you can do it.
It seems like it would be further,
but I guess not.
You must have to go around like
through Jordan or something.
Steven Pressfield's new book, "A Man at Arms."
There's a similar journey
that takes place in that novel.
I seem to recall it takes these people
a little bit longer than seven days.
They were loafing.
Well no ways.
What are you gonna do?
Exactly no ways.
I found deficient.
And like the monochrome of the desert.
I mean, how do you know where you're going?
Polynesians they were not.
I mean you could say
a lot of good things about Jews.
They were not guiding themselves by the stars.
The did not.
How are you doing otherwise?
Good man.
I was back out in the cold murky Pacific ocean.
What's the temp these days.
It was 53, 54.
It was pretty cold.
And it was like usually
the clarity is decent enough.
I mean, often it can get murky
but often it's also really blue.
This time it was like we're swimming
through the remains of a million jellyfish.
Brown and green and stringy and cold.
But you know, that's what is so fun about
that swim around that reef
and is that it's still always beautiful.
So it's always a good idea.
Did it give you, a moment to ponder
the themes of "Seaspiracy"
which we're gonna talk about a little bit later?
No, 'cause I hadn't watched it yet.
Oh you hadn't.
I crammed for my studies last night.
Last minute.
I was the last one minute geek,
but I was thinking about Alexey Molchanov
and how cold it was for him and how cold it was.
Do we wanna talk about that right now?
It's not a win of the week?
It is, but you can have tip it.
I'll have tip it to another world record
for free dive champion eXtrordinaire, Alexey Molchanov
he dove 80 meters in a Lake in Siberia.
Underneath the ice.
What was the water temp there?
It was one to two degrees Celsius.
So 35.
That's nuts.
And he was in a seven mil
but he actually did the test dive
the day before in a five mil.
And I was in triathlon wetsuit
which has some close to five millimeter panels
and others you know how they are, they're mixed panels.
And I was in 53, 54 degree water
and I wasn't diving 80 meters.
Well you wrote a great piece for the New York Times.
Thank you.
Once again, being the free diving corresponded
at large for the Times.
But what's cool about in addition to just being
a very well-written piece,
I guess we're kind of talking about it.
Well, we can shelve it and talk about it later,
but is the presentation,
like the multimedia aspects of storytelling
that the Times seems to really be embracing,
'cause it's on a it's on another level.
And they like it
and it helps actually get more eyeballs to it.
It happened with Maya's record wave as well.
When you can get video, it's setting it apart.
And that is definitely a driver
to the stories when I'm selling them.
On a fitness level, are you resting
on your four by four by 48 laurels?
Or have you been able to know perpetuate the momentum?
Well, it's funny
because I knew I was doing four by four by 48,
I've I kind of joined one
of these Garmin challenges for like a badge.
And so through March 31st,
I'm supposed to have run 505 kilometers
from January 1st to March 31st
for the first quarter.
And I'm close to that marker.
So I've got to knock that off by Wednesday.
And I've been getting some zone two motivation,
couple of your listeners.
One more recently reached out
and said that when he started zone twoing
three years ago, he was
running 12 minute mile zone twos.
And now he's doing extended periods in the low sevens.
Wow that's huge progress.
Everybody who has reached out to me,
I really appreciate it.
And that kind of stuff is very motivating.
And I have been continuing to do my zone two stuff
and I'm not resting.
I've been trying, it's hard
'cause I wanna keep running five, six days a week,
but I'd like to get in the ocean too.
And I just have limited amount of time.
So it's a matter of choosing.
I think if you intersperse, like, I don't know
that you need to run six days a week.
I don't run that much.
I mean, I think if you intersperse it
with some swims it'll actually benefit your running.
But perpetuating that, like dedication to zone two
it's playing a long game.
I get so much feedback
from people saying
"I tried the zone two thing
but I just got bored or I gave up
or I wasn't seeing progress or it wasn't working."
And I think people are just impatient.
Like it works, but you have
to really dedicate yourself to it.
And it does require a different kind of discipline
'cause you have to let go
of everything you think you know,
about what it means to get fit
and just understand
that you're gonna be on a journey for a long time.
And you're not gonna see results
for quite an extended period of time.
But then when it starts to kick in,
it really makes a huge difference.
As in the case of that example, you decided.
I feel like I've shaved in six months,
a minute off my mile time.
And that's huge.
Average, mile time in zone two.
So it's not about getting faster,
it's becoming more efficient
so that the strain on your body is reduced.
And what, you used to be able to do
at a 10 minute pace or whatever.
If you're doing it at a nine minute pace
with the same amount of output,
just continuing that trend
imagine running seven minute miles
and having it feel like it feels
like when you're running 10 minute miles.
That's my dream.
And that's why I feel like
I am starting to see some small movement.
And I also like, mostly I'm feeling it on my feet
which 'cause I used to be such a pounder.
And I'd be hammering.
You could hear me come in
from a hundred miles away.
Shaking the buildings.
And now I'm really just like
I'm very quiet now compared to what I used to be.
And not just the breath, but my footsteps.
Cool.
And so I do feel like that's helping
but at the same time, my form is not great.
There's a lot of improvement that can happen.
And then Nicholas just messaged me this morning.
There's some swim run challenge happening
in June where he's trying to get
like teams around the world
to pile up the swim run miles
and to have some sort of virtual competition.
I'll look at that and I'll bring it to you.
That's cool.
I had my coach, Chris Hauth & Caroline Burckle
in here the other day.
And Chris is training for a trans Tahoe assault.
Really?
Where he's gonna go end to end.
I can't remember how many miles it is
like 28 or something like that.
And he's trying to recruit Caroline
and I to swim segments and crew him.
And I haven't been swimming at all.
Like their pools are so difficult to get into
and I'm not thrilled about getting into 53 degree water.
I mean it's fine for a plunge
but like for training, that's a different thing.
So I don't know.
I got a text this morning putting some pressure on me.
You gotta do it, man.
Let's get up there.
We'll see what happens.
How are you, what's going on in your space?
I'm all right.
I'm a little foggy and groggy today.
So if I lapse into kind of a zoned out space,
it's on you to carry this podcast.
I just didn't sleep well last night,
we're recording this on Monday.
What's the day today?
The 29th full moon has been in full effect.
The last couple of days,
actually it's been really dramatic in LA
with it resting low on the horizon and it looked huge.
And I don't know what it is.
I think we talked about this before.
Like I just don't sleep great on the full moon.
Because you're outside.
So I'm feeling a little off today.
Julie's out of town with one of our daughter.
So I'm on kid duty, home duty.
It's been a busy past week
getting in some interesting training in the gym.
It's weird.
Like I've really committed
to this strength program that I'm on.
And I feel like my body's changing.
I touch a weight and I like bulk up immediately.
So I feel like bulky.
And it feels good to be strong.
Like I haven't felt this way in a long time
but my body is changing
in a way that I'm not used to.
I'm used to being very lean and agile.
And now I feel like this brick walking around.
Really.
I'm going from hippie trail guy,
with a long beard to like basically,
playing volleyball in "Top Gun."
That's kind of like the trajectory that I'm on.
I wanna get back.
Now it's like summer out.
I just wanted more outdoors.
I'm not a gym rat,
but I really do wanna
take this thing to another level
and get strong and see where that leads.
How's the back?
So it's good.
I've been doing the cold plunging
and that's been great.
I've got the temp down to like 46 now
I'm taking it down like two degrees
every couple of days.
And how long you are you in for?
I wanna work down towards to 39.
But I do three rounds of four minutes alternating.
We have also have an outdoor bathtub.
So I put hot water on that and I go back and forth.
So I do four minutes in the tub, three rounds.
And it's been good and I'm adjusting to it.
When I first started at like 54 degrees,
I'd be like shivering.
And now I just get in
and I'm like, this feels awesome.
Like you do acclimate to it.
Not that it gets easier,
it's still kind of a shock
but I look forward to it now.
And it really is quite refreshing,
especially if you do it in the late afternoon
when your energy is starting to lull.
It's like taking a two hour nap
and it's really helping my back a lot
which has been great.
And you get to 39, you say.
I'm enjoying that.
We're hard at work on "Voicing Change Volume Two".
Which is cool.
I keep trying to carve out time to work on that book,
but this podcast takes up a lot of time brother.
This particular one?
What can I tell you.
But I have made time to get out on some gravel
with my e-bike, which has been really fun.
It's just opened up like all these trails
that are kind of too far away for me to run
but now I'm exploring them on two wheels
and that's been super fun.
I can get from my house all the way
over to the West side and tour all around.
And it's just like a whole different part
of LA has suddenly opened up to me
and the weather's gotten nice, super warm.
I rode both Saturday and Sunday and that was great.
And then last night just working
on getting the Alex Honnold podcast up
which just went live, which is super fun.
Early feedback on that is great.
Got some good stuff coming up.
Matthew Walker is doing the show on Saturday.
People know him as one of
if not the preeminent authorities on sleep.
He wrote this amazing book, "Why We Sleep."
So I'm really looking forward to podcasting with him.
I read his book when it came out
and now I'm listening to it on audio book,
which has been great.
And a really cool development is
that it looks like in two weeks,
we're gonna travel
to Minneapolis to do a series of interviews
including a sit down with the mayor there, Jacob Fry.
As many people know today,
the trial just began the Derek Chauvin trial.
He's the officer who's being charged
with second and third degree murder of George Floyd.
So that's City is on pins and needles.
And I think it would be a really interesting boots
on the ground experience to go there
and kind of get a sense of what's happening there.
No doubt about it though.
That's gonna be incredible for you to get in there
and weigh in and feel it should be heavy.
And by then, who knows where the trial will be?
I know.
I can't imagine the stress
that the Mayor is shouldering at the moment.
He could suddenly become unavailable
but I just think it's important.
I wanna understand it better
and the opportunity presented itself.
How did that come?
Through my buddy Brogan Graham,
who's been on the show.
He's a buddy of mine.
He's the founder of November Project.
He used to live in San Diego
but he moved to Minneapolis a couple of years ago.
And he's running buddies with Jacob Mayor Fry.
You said he's a really good runner.
Mayor Fry's a very good runner.
So hopefully get out
on a run with him as well
which should be interesting.
In other news, I got into a bit of a Twitter spat.
I saw that.
The other day.
Well, it's kind of a one-sided Twitter.
It's not like he responded.
No he didn't.
But I don't know.
I was feeling like a little bit spicy
in response to this tweet
that was posted
by Senator Dr. Roger Marshall from Kansas.
There was a video he's railing against meatless, Mondays.
Like it's some kind of crazy government overreach
and he was spouting, he's a physician
but he was spouting all this nutritional nonsense
and I just couldn't let it stand.
Old school.
So I pop in there and kind of shared my,
I don't do that.
Like I'm not like-
You were polite.
A shit-stir on Twitter.
But you were polite.
Was I polite?
You were you said excuse me Senator.
Well I said "Senator."
And that was kind of snide I think actually,
but the engagement
on that tweet was so crazy.
And I was like,
oh this is how people build
their following on Twitter(crosstalk)
they say outrageous stuff.
He was doing it to though.
Not that that's gonna become a common practice.
I mean he was attacking meatless,
he opened the door and he-
Well he was saying all kinds of stuff.
It was in reference to imposing
meatless Mondays in high schools.
And he was saying that if you're a high school athlete
there's no way that you can make this work.
It's gonna be impairing children.
And I just think that that's untrue and silly.
Why would you take good protein out of it?
And this is a guy who propped up by big Ag
and the meat and dairy industry.
So he's probably on the receiving end
of some lobbying dollars.
And his constituency is making sure
that those industries are chugging away as always.
So of course, he's gonna take the side
of those industries
and the government overreach isn't meatless Mondays
the government overreach is propping up this industry.
That's going the way of the Dodo.
No doubt.
And he's also in the receiving end
of Rich Roll booting his ass
I'll tell you that.
Not really.
No it wasn't like that.
Anyway and also we should talk
about Kevin Ruse who was on the show.
Famous artists.
Now he's.
Basically is one
of the most highly paid artists in the world right?
Yes.
It kind of came on our podcast,
we were talking about NFTs
and he was considering the idea
of doing a book and releasing it as an NFT.
But what he did on the heels
of the podcast was release an article
which was about NFTs as an NFT.
And he auctioned off that article
the first in the 170 year history
of the New York Times to be distributed
as an NFT a PNG file
that ended up at auction raising
over $500,000 for charity, which is bananas.
Who wants that?
Well, it's like, I have the first NFT
from the New York Times ever.
I guess it's bragging rights.
I mean who wants the Mona Lisa?
And we can go down this rabbit hole again,
but I think whether you can get on board
with this idea or not
this is the world that we now live in.
It's a currency.
Is what it is.
It's just another currency.
In certain respects.
I mean, it's a currency,
like a painting is a currency, I suppose
it's a non fungible token Adam is what it is.
I know what it is yet
I have no idea what it is.
The kind of just Metta nature of the whole thing.
And also Kevin's sheer confusion and delight on Twitter
and how this thing unfolded was really kind
of fun watching that.
What's Kevin's take on this?
What do you think?
Zero? I mean, it's for charity, right?
Oh yeah.
His financial take was nothing.
I thought you meant his like hot take?
No I'm sure the part of him was like damn.
He's like, well, I'm sure he's thinking
maybe I really should do that book as an NFT.
And it's made me think,
'cause we talked about this last time
about creating an NFT
from the first episode of this podcast.
And of course there's the environmental concerns
which are the real impediment.
I would have done it already if it wasn't for that.
But how does that balance
out if we auction it off for charity?
Are you looking for me to enable this NFT adventure?
'Cause I am your hype man.
I'm gonna call your Allen on Sponsor.
Go for it.
I sign that my job is to say, go for it.
That's not your job.
Your job is to tell me what you think.
I think that you should wait until it's on to that.
It's like Etherium.
And just wait.
But then the bubble will be burst.
It's true.
What do you think the first episode would go for?
But what if we raised, we gave the money to
like the Honnold Foundation
which is all about solar energy.
So how would that balance out,
I guess it would depend on how much you raised
as to whether it would cancel
out the carbon footprint
that was required to mint the NFT in the first place.
This particular riddle requires
a smarter person than me.
I know that people ask.
Some sort of blockchain person,
that can run the numbers on that.
Exactly. Maybe we need the blockchain
to run the numbers
if we should do the blockchain.
Should we turn to the Iron Cowboy Ticker?
How about this guy picking it up?
This has become like a,
just basically a cornerstone of roll-on.
Like checking in on the Iron Cowboy.
How can it not be
this guy is like gone from basically barely making
through these marathons
to actually picking up the pace and going hard.
He does seem to have had a bit of a renaissance
in terms of his energy and enthusiasm and mood lately.
Hasn't he?
So we're on day 29 as of today, which is Monday,
he is going strong.
There is this turning of the tide.
He looks strong, his mood seems elevated
and all of this despite
what appears to be some pretty insane weather
that they've gone through.
If I was him I would've started this thing in like May.
But he doesn't like the heat.
It's hot there.
He doesn't do well with the heat
but instead he's going through sleet
and snow storms and all kinds of stuff.
He does maintain a pretty high vibe.
So I have kind of a positive,
negative spin on all of this.
Give it to me.
But before we get into that.
Let's talk about the why,
because that's something we talked about
when you were heading into the Goggins challenge
and James posted about that the other day.
He posted about the why?
Do you think that was a call back
on your question about the why?
You think he listened to the podcast
And he's like, "I need to declare my why?"
No, I don't I think so.
So this is something
that the you Ultra athletes talk
about your why's a lot?
I feel like there's a snarkiness
in how you just said that.
I didn't mean it that way. No.
You ultra athletes like to talk about the why
like it's some kind of
like sort of a mental exercise and nonsense.
Or mental exercise period,
just like in the fact that like
it's something that you guys do consider
and talk about and think about
before taking on something
that's seems kind of like a superhuman attempt.
It's not something-
But I think that should be a question everybody
should be asking themselves all the time
about whatever it is that they're investing
their time and energy in.
But he said specifically
that his why was knowing
there are millions of people in the world
that need a little spark to light their sparkle
and don't know where to find that spark.
In his words, "If I can be the spark
for just one person
to believe in themselves, that's enough."
And I think that's great.
I appreciate that.
And you know what I like about it is that,
it's honest, what you see a lot
with endurance athletes,
they'll declare their why as being a charity,
or I'm doing this for the kids
or I'm doing this for spinal bifida
or whatever it is.
And those are all laudable things
to raise money for charity,
which is something that James is also doing
in the pursuit of this goal.
But I always find those to be somewhat disingenuous.
It's like, you're really doing it for you.
Come on, you know what I mean?
Like, let's be honest
No one spends a hundred days.
You're doing it to see if you can do it.
And there's nothing wrong with that.
You don't have to say you're doing it
because of this other thing.
But I think that I find James's
declaration on this to be quite earnest
and I think it's cool.
And listen I'm a huge fan
as many of you guys know
I was early on board with James
before he even attempted
his 50 iron mans in 50 States in 50 days,
I had him on the show
when very few people were paying attention
to what he was doing.
I had him on after the show
I ran the final marathon with him in that attempt.
And I've always elevated this guy's message.
I just think he's a beautiful, amazing soul
an incredible athlete, of course,
an incredible family man.
I've had the opportunity
to see him deliver his keynote.
He's a very gifted public speaker.
His presentation is unbelievable.
And what I like about this Conquer 100 challenge
the sort of feat itself aside,
is how incredibly inclusive
and participatory it is.
He's developed this amazing community around this event.
He's got crazy support.
All these people that show up every single day.
On Instagram he's just crushing the Instagram game.
That's amazing.
With amazing stories constantly.
Who's doing that you think?
Well, I think his daughter
and his wife, Sonny
are probably managing most of it.
That's amazing.
His daughter is crushing it.
She's checking in all the time.
Sonny started sharing her perspective on stuff
and answering questions
that people have for her.
Like, what's it like to be James' wife?
And how are you taking care of yourself
and all of that.
And she's been very kind of engaged and forthright
about where she's coming
from on all of this,
which I think is cool.
He's got his wingman
Aaron Hopkinson and Casey Robles who are just hilarious.
I mean, these guys, talk about good friends.
They just show up for James 110%.
They did this on the 50, 50, 50,
they're doing it again.
And they're like comedians.
Like they're participating alongside of him
but they keep the mood light.
They're literally his court jesters
and his ultimate support team.
They're super cool.
You have to laugh at it.
Well the absurdity of the whole thing.
Because it is this huge dark tunnel he's in.
But the thing is you would think
that it would all be about the darkness
and the heaviness
but when you watch the Instagram stories
it's like, they're laughing.
They're having fun.
They're joking.
And I guess that's a strategy.
I just know when I'm super tired,
it's very hard to get into that head space.
You become really grumpy
and difficult to be around.
And he seems to be pretty jovial
and convivial throughout
the entire thing, which is unbelievable.
So that's cool.
I mean, these guys
Aaron and Casey truly BFF goals.
If you could be so lucky
to have friends like these guys.
And the fact that they all seem to be having fun.
I think that's great.
I mean, so that's the positive.
But I think I would be remiss
and not sort of sharing a different side of this.
I think what's unique about James is that,
typically the mind caves into the body.
And Goggins talks about this all the time.
The mind gives in,
when the body still has 40% left or whatever
it's the mind that goes first
when the body is capable of more.
But I think with James,
it's actually the opposite.
I think this guy's mind
is much stronger than his body.
Maybe his mind is 40% stronger than his body.
And that's very unique
and something to be celebrated
but he's so mentally tough
that I think if he had his leg amputated
in the middle of this whole thing
that he'd still figure out a way to like finish it.
I have no doubt that he possesses the will
to complete this insane challenge.
And that he will very well compel
his body to complete it.
But I do think it would be irresponsible
if I didn't at least voice
some concern regarding the long-term
health complications
that he's risking by doing this.
I love James.
I don't want him to break his body beyond repair
and end up walking with a cane at 40.
And I suspect that
under the best circumstances
if he completes this,
even if he pulled the plug now
it's gonna take his body
a really long time to recover.
It could be a year.
It could be years.
I mean the adrenal fatigue alone.
So if anybody can do it,
this guy can certainly do it.
I don't doubt him for a second,
but I would just hate to see him
push his body beyond irreparable limits.
So do you want him to tap out?
No I don't want him to tap out.
I know that he has a lot of support
and he goes home during the transitions
and at night he's got all kinds
of people working on him.
So I presume that he's having his blood drawn
and he's got doctors who are monitoring him
and all of that
who would tell him, "Look, you're digging a hole.
You're not gonna be able to crawl out of."
If faced with that kind of medical diagnosis
would he pull the plug or would he keep going?
I don't know the answer to that
but I just care for him.
I just don't wanna see him get harmed
in the pursuit of this challenge. That's all.
I feel like the swim is kind of a break for him.
Like the swim, isn't the hard part.
The swim is like recovery.
It's a part of the recovery.
But you see him crawling out of the pool.
Like how ginger he is on his feet.
And you're like this dude is work.
So of course he is.
It doesn't look easy
to get up that ladder.
That's gotta be a very tall ladder.
He's like "Fuck now it's the real shit."
And it's either something soothing
about like every day you see him crawl
up the ladder and put his Crocs on
and like saunter over into the locker.
And it's like, oh man now it's real.
It's like a metronome
He's like, "God, I like that pool.
Maybe I wish it was five miles on the pool."
Anyway, send him your love.
Follow him on Instagram @ironcowboyjames.
And we love you James.
It's very impressive, James.
I just love his little motivation tactics
like were wearing 23
and having LeBron be the theme of 23
and then each day is a different theme.
And just seeing that-
You gotta mix it up though.
You gotta keep every day fresh.
Otherwise I think they switched
up the course a little bit recently.
Yeah, and he likes that better.
I am excited.
Towards the end we should really road trip out there.
We'll figure that out.
I mean what happened with the 50, 50, 50
I went out there,
I was there for the final day
and was hoping to get a podcast with him
obviously not right after
but I hung around the day after
and he was just too,
it wasn't gonna happen.
So I went home and then flew back
like a week or two later and did it.
But it's historic and something to be celebrated.
But if you go out there don't bring the gravel bike,
'cause it would be rude to have a motor.
That would be rude.
How dare you?
No, I would never do that.
Can you imagine?
Seriously, bro.
It has been funny.
Like I've posted my gravel rides on Strava.
There is an e-bike, it'll upload
and then I gotta quickly switch it to e-bike.
So I'm not holding myself out
as having rode a route,
'cause the stats or whatever.
But there was a couple
like sort of snarky,
like seriously, man, you're on an E.
And I was like, "Look, man, come at me bro.
But I'm having fun.
I'm just enjoying myself."
I love that you're doing that.
And I love the idea
of it's like under the bridge downtown
like I think of that,
"Under the Bridge" from Red Hot Chili Peppers.
"Like I walked through her Hills
'cause she knows who I am" about LA.
And the fact that you're unlocking different canyons
and fire roads, it's like
I think it's awesome.
Its been cool.
To see the city through her canyons
is really the best way to see LA
and to understand it.
And so to be able to do that
and cross that much territory,
it's not a small ride.
No. I mean, I went down Saturday.
I took trails all the way down into Brentwood
through Santa Monica, down through Venice
and then rode back up through PCH,
took Los Floris up yesterday dropped down.
Where did I drop down?
Oh, down into the Palisades
and through the Highlands.
I'd never been there.
You know, that whole like development
in the Palisades it's way up on the Hill.
I'd never knew that existed.
Up through sights.
Which is over like 20 years.
Really?
I mean, I knew there were houses up there
but I'd never driven up there.
I didn't know anything about it.
Isn't that gated up there?
I have been there a couple of times.
But a trail kind of drops you
in at the top up there.
And then just rolls back down anyway-
The e-bike house thieves.
That's gonna be the next thing.
Shout out to Specialized.
Who's my partner in this,
I've been really enjoying working
with him and the Creo is awesome.
I do need to get a legit road bike
and a non e gravel bike at some point.
So I'm working on that.
Shout out to specialized
it's okay I don't want one.
Don't even call me.
I've never seen you on a bike.
I did see you on a Super 73 though.
I have a Fixie.
That's it put gravel tires on it.
I used to ride back in the day
but it's been a long time.
We'll rectify that.
All right, man.
Let's take a break and we'll be back
with the big story and more.
All right.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But first I do want to snag a quick moment
to talk about something I care a lot about
which is the importance of nutrition.
And the thing is most people I know actually
aspire to eat better,
to incorporate more whole plants,
fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans
and legumes into their daily regimen.
Sadly however, without the proper tools
and support very few end up sticking with it.
And so because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly.
And because I want everyone to experience
some version of what I've experienced
we decided to tackle
and solve this very common problem.
And the solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is,
the plant power meal planner.
Our affordable all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands
of customizable, super delicious
easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery.
You get access to our team
of amazing nutrition coaches seven days a week,
and many other amazing features.
To learn more and sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time
we're offering $10 off an annual membership.
When you use the promo code, RRHealth at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff literally
for just a dollar 70 a week,
the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com
promo code RRHealth for $10 off in annual membership.
All right. Back to the pod.
All right we're back.
Adam, we got to talk about guns.
I know man.
This uniquely American obsession that we have.
It sure is.
Since we last convened two mass shootings,
18 people dead in Atlanta a white dude motivated
by anti-Asian misogyny hit three massage parlors
and claimed eight lives.
In Boulder a muslim dude shot up
a grocery store, King Soopers
with an AR-556 pistol.
Bought six days prior,
I think he bought it like the day
of the Atlanta shooting or somewhere(crosstalk).
The guy in Atlanta bought it the day of.
But the Boulder bought it
like the day the Atlanta shooting happened
or the day after or something like that.
The AR-556 being sort of a pistol version of the AR-15.
And here we are, again,
gun violence is up 25% from last year.
Some of that is fueled in part
by intimate partner violence.
Gun purchases are up in part motivated
by people fearing becoming a victim of gun violence.
And we're in this vicious cycle
that as a society we just can't seem
to find our way out of.
I agree.
I personally am starting to feel complicit
to be quite honest with you
because it happens over and over and over again.
And what have I done about it?
I wrote a story about guns
after the Pulse Nightclub shooting
and the the Dallas officers were killed
by that other sniper.
And maybe I gave money to every town or something,
but that's not really doing much.
That's easy if can come from my desk.
I can't say that I've done anything
or participated in the solution.
When this happens I go numb
and then I feel powerless.
And I don't wanna be
among the thoughts and prayers, chorus.
I wanna participate in something meaningful
but it's unclear what exactly that is.
Other than basically voicing outrage on social media
which I don't really think is productive either.
It does nothing.
Let's go through some of the stats.
So we're not gonna talk about thoughts and prayers
because this is a systemic issue
and thoughts and prayers don't solve it.
So America has more guns than any other country
300 million guns,
one for every person in the country.
One for every person.
Japan has less than one gun per 100 people.
And they have 10 deaths a year.
We have gun-related murders
in our country are 25 times higher
than any other country on earth.
We have 3.4 gun murders
per a hundred thousand people.
Next highest is Canada at 0.6.
When you see the graph
we're referencing in New York Times opinion piece.
And they show this graph country by country.
And the U.S. is like, it just looks
like it's 20 fold higher than the next closest country.
And I give Canada a little bit of a pass there.
They're at 0.6, but you know some
of those people were Americans.
Model for regulating guns is the automobile
like right now we have,
you sent me this interesting story
about how the NRA has basically
twisted up the Second Amendment.
So we're in this position
where we have no way to control guns
because of a few reasons.
One is we have this whole chunk of the country
that has become connected to the Second Amendment.
The Second Amendment is the right to bear arms.
That was put in there as kind
of a placeholder for States
to have their own militias.
So there wasn't a centralized army
that dominated different States.
Regulated militias.
Which is it's regulated militias comma,
which is the part of the Second Amendment
that gets glossed over in this conversation.
That's been twisted to be all
about individual gun ownership rights
which is not really the original intent
of the Second Amendment.
And so what happened was the NRA went through a change.
Like in the fifties,
they were about marksmanship training,
firearms safety education,
and in the seventies,
they turned into kind of a legal organization
to expand the application of the Second Amendment
to include private ownership and personal protection.
Why? Because their members,
meaning the arms manufacturers
not the people that pay for membership fees
the individual people
made money off it.
And they made inroads
in the Republican Party mostly.
And throughout government donating
to different campaigns
and next thing you know,
it makes it almost impossible
to pass any legislation, regulating guns.
We call it gun control.
That's really the wrong way to put it.
It's like we don't call driver's licenses-
Car control.
Automobile control or person control.
We're just saying,
let's make sure people are safe
when they're operating something dangerous.
I think the NRA could be rebooted
to be an organization
that does all the things that could help us.
That would be talking about background checks
talking about smart guns,
taking a public health approach and saying,
"If you're gonna own a firearm
these are the things you need to think about."
Everything down the line, marksmanship, hunting classes
all these good things, licensing, certifications
all these things that could actually end up-
Storage.
Use, smart guns.
That if they fall into the hands
of somebody who's not registered
to use it, they don't work.
It is interesting that we've been unable
to make any inroads on that.
And past attempts at gun control,
which have focused on outlawing certain aspects
of guns just end up in endruns
around those details to create something
that's just outside of the regulation
that still achieves the end.
Whether it's a particular scope
or whatever it is on the gun,
I'm no gun expert.
Those have traditionally failed.
And it is interesting.
I mean, what was the inflection point
with the NRA where they tipped
from being this kind of regulatory body
that was heavily invested in education
and the like to now being
this absolutist organization
that basically won't give an inch on any issue
and couches the whole thing
in the context of governments
trying to take your guns away from you.
I think according to that story
what happened was there was,
and you'll link to it.
It's called "How the NRA Rewrote the Second Amendment."
And it used to be on their
I think I have it in here
on their door of their main office in D.C.
were letters that kind of is
like embossed on the door,
"Firearms, safety, education
marksmanship, training, shooting for recreation."
And now there is an abridged version
of the Second Amendment
that it takes it completely out of context.
And I think what happened was there was
a "revolt" against the leadership in the NRA
which at the time was for gun regulation.
From the fifties all the way to the seventies
and the whole board got fired
and someone else took over.
And that so in began this kind
of long game of rewriting laws
and getting through the courts
to expand civil liberties
or I call it civil liberties
but to expand the meaning of these amendments
to include conservative principles like bearing arms.
The second Amendment literally says
"A well-regulated militia comma,
being necessary for the security of a free state comma,
the right of the people to keep and bear arms comma,
shall not be infringed."
So it's a sentence that's rife
for all different kinds of interpretations.
But nowhere in there does it reference directly
the individual's right to bear arms
is specifically in reference
and that comma after regulated militia
to me hammers at home,
that this is all in the context
of arming a regulated militia.
And it's the third clause.
No the individual.
And it's that third clause,
"The right of the people to keep and bear arms
shall not be infringed."
That's the only thing they have on their door now.
So the first part of it gets forgotten.
And I think the founding fathers
would be turning in their graves
at how this has been exploited.
So what's the way forward?
I mean, one of the arguments
that gets thrown around a lot is,
it's a mental health argument.
This is about the mental health of these people.
This idea that we have more mass shootings
because we have more mental health problems.
But the data doesn't really support that.
Countries with high suicide rates
tend to have low rates of mass shootings.
They found that video games don't correlate,
racial diversity
and immigration issues also don't correlate.
And it really is.
And this is born out by the data
that it's about access to guns,
the more access you have to guns
the more shootings
and deaths you're going to have.
And if we look at a couple
of different case studies
Sandy Hook being, obviously one
of the most horrific,
every one of them is horrific.
Sandy Hook is obviously on a scale
because we're talking
about kindergarten children and whatnot.
There was I think, an advertisement
that was connected to that,
where he bought a certain rifle
or he wanted that rifle.
His mother bought it for him as a gift
because it was a lot like some ad he'd seen
whereas it's about young men empowerment.
And he went out and did that horrible crime.
And right afterwards the victims couldn't really
sue the gun manufacturer
because the government had passed a law,
basically a rider on some other law
making it impossible to sue companies
for use of their products in a crime.
It had been challenged a couple of times
it always had been upheld.
A lawyer in Connecticut named Josh Koskoff
took on that challenge of maybe challenging.
He found another way of arguing against that
and the gun manufacturers and the NRA
didn't take it seriously.
'Cause I'd won so many times on it
and they showed up in court
and the judge gave them the go ahead to sue.
And it became this new way
of approaching this problem basically.
'Cause if the company is now suddenly-
Kind of like using RICO to go after the mob.
Exactly.
And if the gun manufacturers suddenly
had to pay the victims of these crimes,
then they will do things
like they wouldn't fight things like smart guns,
where your fingerprint is the only way
that you can figure it.
It's an alignment of incentives, basically.
So when the gun manufacturer is not incentivized
to make sure that these things are safe
and from a product liability perspective
can make the argument
that the gun was used
in the manner in which it was manufactured.
There was nothing dysfunctional about the gun.
The gun was used and the gun worked properly.
So therefore the gun manufacturer
bears no culpability for this.
But if you say that's the argument.
But if you say, actually they do
where are you hanging your hat
on that argument though?
I'm trying to wrap my head around how that works.
The argument is if you are creating a product
and advertising a product in a certain way,
and then it's used,
and you pretend it's not your fault.
Basically you have some responsibility
for your product and how it's used.
Why are you selling it?
That's tricky though.
Like where do you draw the line with that?
Well, that's the question.
So the real question is,
we should all be asking ourselves
is why can we go in
and buy an AR-15 with high capacity magazines
and things like that.
What's the use of that?
It doesn't make any sense.
It's absolutely insane.
It's totally outrageous.
It makes me furious.
Why can't we get our shit together?
The citizenship is overwhelmingly in favor
of universal background checks.
There are so many things that we can do.
Gun owners are in favor.
90% or something.
There's so many things that we could do.
And it's interesting when you look
at how the NRA has handled this
by not budging, not giving an inch,
like that's the strategy
like never give in on anything
because it's slippery slope.
And because of that tactic
then they've been able to create the situation
that we're in right now.
But the truth is we need,
well-informed logical,
rational regulation of this landscape.
It's insane.
It is insane.
That we're in this situation
and it's gonna continue to perpetuate
unless we do something.
So now we have Joe Biden is president.
We've got a Democrat controlled House and Senate,
can we get something done here?
Well the answer to that is,
will the Democrats wave the filibuster?
Because the only way you're gonna get 60 senators
to support any sort of law
in terms of regulation of firearms
is going to be to get the Republicans to vote for it A.
A and you need at least nine of them
which I think is a reach
'cause you need 60 votes to override, a filibuster
or you kind of throw away the filibuster for this issue.
And if you do that,
what happens in the future?
But that's the question.
And it doesn't look like that's happening.
He's moving on to infrastructure first.
He's gonna do something.
We'll see what he proposes.
We have this kind of blur cocktail
in this country of racism, misogyny, religion and guns.
And this growing absolutism
on either side of any hot button issue.
So it makes it hard
to communicate across party lines
and to get anything real done.
And then when you have
like take the Atlanta shooting
he was the son of a pastor
an evangelical kind of minister.
He felt he was in violation of his
whatever full of lust or whatever.
And his solution to that is to eliminate women
who are struggling just to get by,
working in the spas
in the red light district of Atlanta.
I mean, that's his solution to his own problems.
It's a complicated one
because on the one hand
it's basically an anti-Asian hate crime
but it was really motivated
by this guy's internal conflict
as much as it was.
I don't know that had those
massage parlors been populated
with masseuses that weren't Asian,
that it would have been any different.
I don't know enough about it to comment
on that one way or the other
but I think it's complicated in that regard
when you dive into like motive
but part of that motive was his guilt.
It was a religiously motivated crime in ways.
It was.
I think he might've felt the women were less disposal
maybe if they weren't Asian.
That's a good point.
And then there's the whole history
and the certain context now
of all the anti-Asian hate crimes
that are happening all
over the country in San Francisco
and New York specifically the most, but happening elsewhere.
And then this one pops up as kind
of like it just it's part of it.
And he bought his gun the day
of the shooting the nine millimeter pistol.
That's crazy.
The day of.
It's crazy.
You can't tell me, that's not the...
Like of all these things
I just mentioned racism, misogyny, religion, and guns
which is the one you can control the easiest?
'Cause we're not looking to control the others.
You can't control them.
You can't control a person-
Set against the backdrop where gun-related murders
in the United States are 25% higher
than in any other country.
It's so glaringly obvious
that we need to readdress this in a meaningful way.
And yet our ineptitude,
because we're so caught up in these traditions
and this ideology that surrounds guns.
Literally people are just getting slaughtered.
I was talking a lot about this with my wife.
My wife's from Australia, she's from Sydney.
In Australia they had their own Columbine
and it didn't take long
for them to pass legislation,
to have people turn in their own guns.
And I'm not suggesting
that we call for everyone turning in their guns.
So don't apt me about that.
But I'm just saying that happened in Australia
and now she sees this happen
and it's not the first one
since she's been in the country,
she's seen a number of them now.
And then what is the news the next day it's in Georgia,
after this Atlanta shooting,
the thing that's making news the laws
that they pass in the state of Georgia
is to make it illegal,
to bring water to someone standing in line to vote.
That's what they did.
And she's like, "Where are the priorities
of these leaders like,
that's what they're doing with their time?"
It's astonishing the lack
of leadership in this country.
And it's-
Well, meanwhile, wasn't it
the Texas governor was bombed
that Texas was only second in terms of gun purchases.
And he publicly said something like,
we gotta be number one.
Who are these donkeys dude?
How do you vote for these people?
I don't understand.
And then you have this black lawmaker woman
who was trying to, I forget her name.
I don't have it at my fingertips, forgive me.
But she was trying to knock
on the door of the Governor
while he was signing that voting-
In Georgia.
They're in the voting control
not gun control in Georgia
and she was arrested.
And if you look at the video
of her getting dragged away
by those guys and crew cuts
it could have been like "Bull" Connor era.
Like these bullheaded guys
are dragging this professional woman down the halls
when she was just trying to knock
on the door, the Governor.
Where are we?
What is happening in this country?
It's appalling.
And it does scare me.
And it makes me wonder,
where do I belong in this place?
If we can't figure out,
we have kids,
if you can't trust the leaders
to remove real big obstacles
for children, 'cause you can.
We've had it
with you used to be able to nurse your baby
in the back seat.
Now they have to be in a car seat.
Why is that?
Didn't Delta airlines get dragged
because they supported that voter suppression law.
Did they?
There was something about that.
I don't know enough about it.
There was a headline about that.
But is Atlanta that Delta hub?
Atlanta is the Delta hub.
So I don't know if that has something to do with that.
And then you have Boulder, like that's Atlanta.
And then in Boulder you have,
this is what they
had Columbine in 99,
Aurora in the movie theater shooting.
They had something in Colorado Springs
at the abortion clinic.
And now you have King Soopers in Boulder.
That's right.
And they've had, like, I think there's more
if you count any multiples of people getting shot
and killed it's it's beyond those four,
but those are like the four real big mass shootings.
And it just keeps happening in Colorado.
So there is one thing
that I've been thinking about,
and that is if you look
at the Vietnam war protests
and what happened then.
The reason that that turned
and we got out of Vietnam
there were some major reasons.
One of them though,
is that the draft had happened
and you couldn't get out of it anymore.
And so now all of a sudden teenagers realize
it was their own life and death at stake.
It was no longer just about this dodgy war
and this oppression of people far away.
And this military industrial complex,
it was about
"I might get drafted and I might die."
And so people went nuts
and they hit the streets
and it grew and it grew and it grew.
And eventually the government caved,
well we need an uprising like that
because more Americans have died
of gun violence in America
than had been killed in every single war combined.
So it is a direct threat to us all.
It's such a diffused threat.
We don't feel it.
That diffusion is at odds with progress though
because we don't feel it
or process it in the same way.
But it is as big a threat or a bigger threat.
And I think that's what it's gonna take.
It's gonna take a massive grassroots mobilization
like what we saw this summer with BLM
but around gun regulation,
that's what it's going to take.
It's hard not to be pessimistic though
because we've just been
around this carousel so many times
and the outrage cycle just continues.
It dissipates.
And then here we go again.
And you're right.
If we can't get it done now
if we can't waive the filibuster for this like-
I know.
What can we do?
I know the fucking filibuster.
And then there's the Supreme Court
just waiting there as well.
All right, well more will be revealed.
Let's move on.
We got a couple more things
we've got to talk about.
All right.
Should we talk about, it feels really like-
This is what they call a bad segue.
This is the worst segue ever.
But we have this, my friend, Toby Morse.
Shout out to Toby punk rocker from H2O.
My friend, he's been on the show.
I did his podcast.
When I did his podcast
he had cans of this stuff called Liquid Death,
which is a really bad segue
from what we were just talking about.
Not a good segue.
But it's basically these cans
that it looks like malt liquor.
They're like 16 ounce black and gold.
I remember those.
With like Gothic writing on it.
It's basically sparkling water though.
It's like LaCroix for punk rockers.
And Toby just had like multiple cases
of this stuff just sent to the studio.
So I just wanted to thank Toby and Liquid Death.
I actually like this.
Thanks Toby. It's good.
But it's kind of hilarious.
It's sort of like if you're really dark and edgy,
you can feel good about your sparkling water, I guess.
I don't know.
It's all marketing.
It's punk rock Pellegrino.
Basically that's what it is.
Let's talk about "Seaspiracy."
Let's talk about it.
You hadn't watched it
when you went out into the frigid Pacific,
but you've watched it since.
I've since watched it.
So "Seaspiracy" many of you
have probably seen it by now,
premiered on Netflix last week.
Produced by friend of the pod Kip Anderson.
Who's the co-director along
with Keegan Kuhn on "Cowspiracy"
and "What the Health," this film, he did not direct
or co-direct, it was directed by Ali Tabrizi.
And it basically is this comprehensive 360
look at what we're doing to our oceans.
It's a deep dive into Marine destruction, corruption
and it's similar to "Cowspiracy" in that
it kind of adopts a similar storytelling architecture
and dives into the conflicts of interest that exist
between environmental groups
that we trust to protect ecosystems, being funded
by organizations that profit from Marine exploitation.
The fishing industry, the Marine park industry, et cetera.
And it's very well done.
The cinematography, the editing is compelling.
Ali is much like Kip in "Cowspiracy."
Ali is the protagonist.
He's the filmmaker and the protagonist in this story.
Who goes on this adventure to learn more
about what exactly is going on in our oceans.
And I think it's very effective
at revealing some uncomfortable truths
about the fishing industry
about the environmental organizations that are charged
with protecting these waterways.
And getting into some details
about things like bycatch
and farm-raised fish,
human rights implications and abuses
that you see throughout Southeast Asia.
And I was very impacted by it.
I've been trying to get Kip and Ali on the podcast.
Kip I don't know if he wants people to know where he is
but he's not in the United States right now.
Ali lives in London.
I'd really like to get both
of them on the show to talk about the movie.
I'm hopeful that at some point I can make that happen.
But until then, it's just you
and I brother talking about this movie.
All right.
You had an interesting take on it though.
I do. Well, I don't know if it's interesting,
but I have a take.
I think I have a few takes.
One is it's great to see young filmmaker dive
into this world with such passion and energy and heart.
He clearly loves the ocean,
cares about it just like we do,
and he's gifted with a camera.
It's crazy those sequences of him as a kid
and he's literally wearing the Jacques Cousteau's red hat
and he's got the striped shirt,
like he was channeling
you could see his future being forecast.
And he cares a lot
and that's really important.
And so I'm all for it.
Powerful footage, especially at the end
and good call to action.
So at the end as well,
I don't wanna spoil it.
We don't wanna spoil it.
But I do have some issues with it.
And the overall one is of sensationalism.
So he covers a grab bag of issues we've seen before
in various documentaries and reporting.
And in my opinion covered better.
"The Cove, Ghost Fleet."
When he gets into the issue with slavery
on Thai fishing boats,
that was covered in a great movie
in 2019 it came out, it's called "Ghost Fleet,"
which is a profile
of a Thai labor activist and Nobel peace prize
nominee named Patima Tungpuchayakul.
And she is based in Thailand.
And she's been responsible
for liberating 7,000 Thai, Burmese,
Lao and Indonesian fishermen
from these kinds of-
Well we could take these points, Siri Adam.
I mean, I think in fairness to Ali and Kip
that movie which I haven't seen
was a single issue focused film
that dove deep into that one thing.
Whereas Ali and Kip are trying
to cover many different things.
So they touch on those human rights abuses
but the whole movie isn't about that one single thing.
And that's something that I knew almost nothing
about other than just
sort of hearing about it tangentially.
That's true.
I mean, I just think overall there was this sense
of taking the worst of the worst cases
like the Maui case in Scotland,
cherry picked stats on fishing
going after third-party certification systems
which I think we talk about fair trade certification
in products which is the same thing
as what the Marine Stewardship Council does.
And kind of casting them as in a very negative light.
And when there's much more nuance involved.
I know about cherry picked stats with fishing
because I did a story on over fishing.
And it's very easy to find a stat
that sounds very alarmist
when you look at all the reports
but if you do deep dives,
you find that different parts
of the world have very different
regulation bodies and governing bodies.
And it's not as simple as it made makes it sound.
So when you're using the most sensationalistic data.
It's not necessarily the best data.
So I would just question that there's this kind
of maximum journalism is the later you are to the story
the smarter you have to be.
And because he's taking on so many different aspects
of what's going on with our oceans
I think it's hard to get to that level.
But you can't also,
and I'll be devil's advocate here
on behalf of the film.
You have to appreciate the spotlight
that these filmmakers are placing
on some pretty horrific ills.
The misalignment of incentives in the labeling industry.
I mean the fact that,
basically these "non-profits"
make their money off of granting labels.
So they're inherently incentivized
to grant these labels.
And then when you have the interview
with the guy and he's like
"Basically I can't guarantee this is dolphin safe."
The dolphin, safe tuna situation.
Its outrageous.
I'm not defending the dolphin safe tuna situation
but the Marine Stewardship Council
is a nonprofit because it is created by, it is funded.
You don't pay for certain-
Well here's the thing.
Certainly there are people doing good things
in the world
and there are well-intentioned activists
and nonprofits out there
that I have no doubt are making
a positive impact in this space.
Clearly the point of this movie
I think if I was to read their minds
was to provide an introductory course
on where we've lost our way
across a variety of different issues
with respect to our relationship with the ocean.
So whether it's commercial fishing
with the trawling and the bycatch.
Whether it's shark fins,
whether it's whaling,
whether it's what's going on in Japan
with the dolphins slaughtering.
Like all of these things are horrible ills
that most people are completely unaware of.
So it's very energizing
and enervating to watch this movie and realize
that this might not be what you think it is.
And your pescatarian diet, which you thought was
on the better end of perhaps a more
ecologically sound nutrition approach
perhaps might be misguided.
When you realize
that it basically disabuses you of this idea
of the fishermen casting his pole into the sea
and pulling out fish one by one.
And you realize the damage
that commercial fishing
is reaping irreparably on the oceans.
When George Monbiot,
who I think is a highlight of the movie.
I've been following him forever,
he writes for the Guardian
on a variety of environmental issues.
He was so solid in the movie.
And when he's talking about,
basically he just puts matters to rights in terms
of how blunt he is about how bad this problem is.
And Oppenlander who also was in "Cowspiracy"
talking about how little
of the oceans are actually protected.
Like, what is it?
5% is meant to be-
5%.
But then it's actually like less than 1%
that's actively protected
and preserved in a responsible manner.
He probably means 1% is no cash zones.
And you're allowed
to have recreational fishing in some MPAs.
I would guess, I would think that
that 5% would preclude commercial fishing.
Maybe there are some MPAs
that allow some regulated commercial fishing.
We've talked about the 30 by 30
that's something I wish this movie got
into more is that there is a movement
afoot internationally to
try to protect 30% of the oceans by 2030.
And that means make them real Marine protected areas.
That's-
And that would demand basically,
the movie makes the point that
that requires a policing effort.
Like the open seas it's anything goes
and you see that being played
out off the coast of Somalia
and what led to basically the whole pirate thing.
Well, so the idea of
if you haven't paid attention,
I mean this is pretty well covered area,
but like Somalia fisheries were decimated
by international fishing units
and whether that was illegal
or whether they paid government officials in Somalia
for the rights to go in
and just take out all the fish.
Basically all these villages along the coast
in Somalia then tried to turn to piracy
because they lost their food source.
I would never defend trawling.
I think commercial fishing has a lot of issues.
I've written about it in the past,
and I'm not in favor
of unregulated fishing, illegal fishing.
I think it's horrible.
But when you make a movie
it would be nice if the stats weren't cherry picked
and if the issues weren't sensationalized
because they are important issues
and you want to make sure people understand them
in a more nuanced way.
If you use the worst case scenario
as your case study then you go
and start to try to have a conversation
with somebody else about it later.
And try to really gather the energy
you end to end up in a conversation
with someone who may be skeptical
of your one movie awakening.
Do you know what I'm saying?
And so I think as a piece of journalism
which a documentary should be,
it would be nice if the facts were the facts
and not used in a sensationalized way,
that's my only point.
But I do agree that highlighting these horrible things
that are happening in the ocean is important.
I think it's-
I mean listen, if you watch the movie
and the only thing you take
from it is what's going on with bycatch and trawling.
Like that's enough.
Enough already look what we're doing to these oceans.
And because it's out of sight, out of mind
we're completely blind and unaware
to the incredibly deleterious environmental impact.
Like when who's the woman
who's this hero at the end, the legendary.
Sylvia Earle.
And she's talking about-
She's fabulous.
She's incredible.
She really anchors it like she gives-
The end is fabulous.
She gives it a gravitas, I think,
and allows you to really kind of embrace the message
because she's so highly credible and such a legend.
But basically her saying
there is no such thing as sustainable fishing.
Like I believe that like Oppenlander said
that in "Cowspiracy" is like
"Fishing is by definition
over fishing at this point."
And to the extent to which we rely-
That's not exactly-
But it is.
And the extent to which we rely
on a robust Marine ecosystem to sequester carbon,
I think is another point that Earle makes
that's so important to understand
and how that's so much more important than,
we put a lot of attention on the rainforest
but we completely overlook the importance
of Marine ecosystems in this equation or draw down.
I agree.
It's out of sight out of mind,
people don't care about the Marine ecosystem
even though it's responsible for every second breath,
the plant life in the ocean
is a carbon sequestrations system
that is number one in the world.
80% or something of our carbon
is sequestered in the ocean.
And the Marine ecosystem is in trouble, reefs are dying.
We're losing kelp forests here,
even just here in Malibu
I don't know if you see them,
but right around starting right before Christmas,
and for several months,
you get trawlers that come in
from Marina Del Ray,
and then from Oxnard and Ventura.
And they come and they scoop up squid
and they bring out their Christmas lights on their ships
and they attract all this squid to the surface.
And then they put their nets out
and they bring them in.
And often they bring in sea lions
and there's guns on these boats
and they shoot sea lion sometimes
'cause sea lion will bite your ass.
Do they bring in dolphins?
They very well might.
We don't know there's not someone out
there really patrolling that.
Well, that's point of the movie
this things are completely unpatrolled.
I totally agree with you.
But there's gonna be an officer
at the Harbor when they come back in.
So there is some control of it in the United States.
I mean, there is some,
and sometimes there's observers on the boats.
That does happen.
But we have problems just here,
but at the same time
there are things we can do.
Marine protected areas are one way
of creating nurseries so fish can replenish.
Like George said in the movie, "Leave the ocean alone."
If you leave the ocean alone,
it will replenish itself.
But the one issue, I will say-
Or it was Paul Watson.
Paul Watson.
He was the Sea Shepherd guy.
They both did I think.
But to say any fishing now is over fishing,
I think is oversimplification.
It's not exactly true.
Like a spear fishermen goes out
and shoots one fish.
That's not over fishing.
That's sustainable mode.
But I think it disabuses you of the idea that,
that's how fishing is performed.
It depends where you're eating your fish.
If you're buying commercial fish
and you don't know
where it's coming from, that's your problem.
But also the movie hammers home the point
that it's very difficult to know
where your fish is coming from.
Its difficult to know.
Even if you're a well minded,
intentional consumer trying to purchase fish
that was raised in a more, I guess I'll say more.
I don't think there's a it's like
I don't eat fish,
but in a more responsible way, I guess.
But there are changes
and he goes after fish farming.
Paul Hawken thinks open ocean Aquaculture is one
of the top 20 things you can do in drawdown.
And an open ocean aquaculture
would be taking fish farm
putting it in ocean where there's current
that blows through there's low density pens.
They're being fed feed
that comes from algae
and from wild fish.
And there are fish farms doing that.
And it's a very small percentage admittedly.
And there is this dream
of maybe somehow stringing clams
and oysters off these pens
which feed off of the fish effluent, the poop
and all of that and grow.
And you have kelp kind of growing
at the same time
and you have this ecosystem to regenerate.
There are different ways
of maybe approaching the problem
but the way in this film,
kind of all fish farms go on-
Predominant fish farm though,
is of the model
that you see in Scotland.
And I think it's-
That's the worst case scenario in the world.
So my point is if you take the worst case scenario
in the world and say
"This is how it is."
I don't know that's responsible journalism,
I guess that's my problem.
I don't know that that Ali or Kip
would call themselves journalists though.
That's the thing.
So you're looking at this
through the eye of an investigative journalist
like that's your approach to the subject matter.
That's not necessarily their approach.
Their approach is more certainly like
it's more activist oriented.
So understanding that,
I think you can appreciate it
for what it is
and the message that it's trying to put out there.
And the kind of energy
that it's trying to bring to this discussion.
So you can hate it, you can love it,
you can disagree with it
but it's provocative enough to provoke conversations
about the subject matter.
It's a hit.
It's a hit, it was in the top 10 on Netflix.
Of course it's beautiful to watch. It's amazing.
And let's just shout out just for a minute.
Sorry. I interrupted you.
But how bad-ass is that fucking Sea Shepherd boat.
I love it.
What's his name?
The guy who created, is it Sam?
A Sam Cedar.
No, not Sam Cedar.
Who started to Sea Shepherd?
No he was a huge donor
to Sea Shepherd before he died of cancer.
I don't know who he is.
I think he created the Simpsons.
So he made a ton of money.
Sam Simpson?
No.
No, no. What am I doing?
I'm gonna have to Google it right now.
Google it.
But Sea Shepherd.
I loved Sea Shepherd.
I mean, what sea shepherd.
And he goes with them in Liberia.
I can't believe I can't remember this.
And Sea Shepherd.
Sam Simon.
Sam Simon?
The boat is called the Sam Simon.
I mean Paul Watson, what he has done
and their work and just recently-
It's incredible.
In the Great Australian Bight to raise awareness
to how much like the Galapagos
of South Australia basically
and how much life there is there.
And they stopped a big oil development project
in South Australia with their work.
I mean they're on the shortlist
of my favorite environmental organizations.
Incredible what they're doing(crosstalk).
Also shout out to a friend
of the pod Paul De Gelder.
It was great to see him.
(crosstalk) on sharks it was amazing.
He was fabulous.
I mean, you're right.
It is a great primer.
Like if you're not familiar with these issues
I'm probably too familiar with these issues.
So then I get grumpy.
Well you're getting caught up Adam come on.
It's like human rights, trawling,
bycatch, shark fin soup.
All these things are new ideas
to a lot of people.
And we just think the ocean is a resource
that will give and give and give forever.
And to appreciate just how delicate it is
and how misinformed so many of us are.
I mean, one of the things
that I liked a lot was the whole
talking about microplastics
and how all the energy goes
into no straws and all of that.
And how little of an impact
that is in comparison to what's really going on.
The commercial fishing.
And where we should be placing our focus.
But I mean, over fishing isn't
as under reported as he thinks it is.
So like, but-
To the average person, it is.
You think it is?
Not to you.
I mean, that's a good question though.
The one question that comes up
for me when I think of these alternate
'cause he talks about plant-based shrimp
and plant-based fish
and these plant-based solutions
and there's shots of him eating it.
The problem when you take this diffused kind
of economy, like fishing was
and certainly subsistence fishing is
and ranching and that kind of thing.
Now there's a whole industrial component
there are certainly big conglomerates
doing some damage out there.
But if you replace it with, a few winners
in this kind of capitalistic game
of there's a few companies doing
these plant-based meats
is that a good replacement?
You know what I mean?
Like get a few people rich
and everybody else is a consumer.
Is that sustainable for the world?
Well, I mean, that's a whole other podcast
that we could do.
I mean, I can go way down the line
with you on that
but right now it may just be a few companies
but there's actually like
if you canvas the startup landscape,
there are tons and tons of companies
that are innovating in the plant-based protein sector
all the way from plant based alternatives
to the cultivated meat landscape
and all the wild stuff
and innovations that are going on there.
Certainly some people are gonna get rich
but these are very early days
and there's plenty of room.
Julie's got a plant-based dairy company
that's very small right now.
Nobody's stopping anybody from-
Joining.
Making a footprint right now.
And there's a lot of money that's being invested
because this is what consumers want.
People wanna believe
that the food choices
that they're making are doing right
by the environment and to the extent
that you can develop a plant-based alternative
to your favorite fish
that is just as nutritionally valuable
that isn't harming the oceans
and plays out in a carbon footprint sense
better than Marine life.
Like, why wouldn't you do that?
That's the world that we're moving towards.
That's the world that I would like to live in
and to kind of coin the sea shepherd guy.
What's his name again?
Paul Watson.
Why do I?
I told you I didn't sleep very well last night.
Captain Paul.
Commander?
Commander.
Is he captain?
He's like, look,
we're on this blue spaceship hurdling across the universe.
And we've got a life support system
and we've got a crew.
And when the crew starts to die,
at some point these life support systems
are gonna start breaking down
and that's what we're happening.
So leave the ocean alone.
And we're so far from that right now
that any inroads in that direction are things
that I'm gonna celebrate.
There you go.
Well, I can't wait to see his next film
he is very talented.
He is right. Cool.
So check it out "Seaspiracy" streaming on Netflix.
How long have we been going on?
We're doing a long podcast today, but we can't.
We've got plenty more.
We still got to get true here.
Let's talk about really quick
'cause I don't want this to be a four hour podcast.
There's a new podcast out called Lost Hills.
That's produced by Pushkin
which is Malcolm Gladwell's company.
It's hosted by Dana Goodyear
who is a new Yorker writer.
And it's all about,
it's a true crime podcast series
that explores this murder
that took place in Malibu Creek, State Park,
which is literally my backyard.
And several attempted murders.
And this all took place in June.
It was all around June, 2018,
where a guy called Tristan Baudette was camping
with his two daughters.
And I think his brother-in-law.
And was shot like basically point blank.
I remember when this went down
and this podcast series tells
the behind the scenes story
of how this happened.
who did it?
And so many more things
that I was unaware of
which are shocking given
that this is my neighborhood.
It was right down the street from you.
Including this guy trying
to pick off cars on Las Virgenes.
Shooting at ongoing cars on Las Virgenes
which is a road I drive on every day.
And I remember when this transpired how
shocking it was to hear about this murder.
But what you find out in listening
to this podcast is that,
the car shootings took place earlier than that.
And there were a couple other people
who were shot at in the park,
like backpackers and stuff.
And none of this was reported to the public.
The Lost Hills Sheriff's Department kept a lid on it.
And had they allowed people
to know what was going on.
Certainly Tristan Baudette
would not have gone camping there
and would probably be alive today.
Probably.
And I just remember how details
and little anecdotes and stories
amongst people who live in the community
started to eke out.
And were like, "What is going on?"
I think at some point
my daughters were going to a school
that was right off Las Virgenes
and they got school was called off
because they found a dead body nearby.
And I mean, we're only on episode three
of this thing like more is gonna happen
but this is a very idyllic part of the world.
And Malibu Creek State Park
is where I go running all the time.
And I can't help but think like I tweeted-
Were you in his sights?
I tweeted, like, don't listen
to the Lost Hills Podcast
while you're trail running.
No you should.
In Malibu Creek State Park
which is exactly what I was doing.
You're like the guy at the beginning
of the Norah movie, running through the maze.
All right this is an amazing, true crime podcast
getting shot at, it's unbelievable
but there's a lot of interesting Malibu characters
that pop up in the storytelling
who are all people that I know.
'Cause I went there.
You know Cece?
I do know Cece.
She comes out well I think.
She's a local muckraker,
I've met her a couple of times.
I just know that she,
I don't know her that well
but I would I see her
on Facebook going off about this
or that the other thing
but she's the one who really got traction
on this whole thing
and got people to pay attention to it.
She rattled the cage of lost Hills Station.
And exposed them.
I mean, I drove by
Lost Hills Sheriff's Department
on my way here today.
Like it's literally our local police department.
So it's just surreal bizarre-
You don't feel very protected, do you?
Well, it's all fine now.
I won't give it away.
But anyway, it's very well done.
Dana and the Pushkin team
and everybody who worked
on the show are there.
I've only listened
to the first three episodes,
but it's pretty fascinating.
If you like true crime
and you like LA Norah.
True crime is where its at.
It's great.
I can't wait for the series.
It will definitely end up as a series
or a movie of the week or something like that.
It's like, what was the "Dirty John?"
This is the whole podcast model now.
I mean, Wondery built its whole business
on that "Dirty Jones" is Wondery
show like just taking
these true crime podcasts
and adapting them for television and movies.
It's gonna be good.
So I wanna do a giveaway.
I got some hats here.
If you're watching on YouTube, Rich Roll Podcast hats
we got a black one,
we got a black and white one.
We got a white and black one.
And also some of these t-shirts
I never wear like my own schwag
but this is the official-
Dude I wear your schwag.
Rich Roll Podcast t-shirt.
So I wanna give away five hats and five t-shirts.
There are three steps to pitch in for this.
The first is subscribe to the YouTube channel.
The second is share one
of your favorite YouTube episodes on social media.
Take a screen grab and email that grab
and subscription confirmation to info@richroll.com.
And we will pick five people for a hat
and five people for a t-shirt.
How's that sound?
Sounds good.
I still, also, I've been remiss.
The book giveaway that we did the other day.
Yeah what about it?
We gotta go through the comments
and pick the pick the winners for that one.
Oh you haven't done it yet?
No we haven't done that.
That's not a good look.
I got it. I'll take care of that this week, for sure.
I'm also getting a lot of comments
about these coffee mugs
the Rich Roll Podcast coffee mugs.
We just have a couple here for the studio,
but so many people seem excited about it.
That's not a mug that's an NFT.
This doesn't actually exist.
Well, if you're watching it on YouTube
it doesn't exist in a three-dimensional space.
But we need to start like taking the drinks
out of our hands as we're sipping them.
So that people wonder if they're really NFTs.
You're going down the matrix rabbit hole.
Have you been red pilled Adam?
I have a friend
who right now is probably still typing
trying to red pill me.
And by the way, this Liquid Death sparkling water
I'm enjoying it,
but they they didn't sponsor the show
or anything like that.
That was just a gift from the company and from Toby.
It's just a comforting gift.
Let's do win of the weeks.
You go.
Wins of the week I should say.
My big win of the week is my buddy Robbie Balenger.
Another friend of the pod.
Many of you might recall.
He came on after he ran across America in 2019.
Well-
As you do.
Last week, March 20th
he set the FKT the fastest known time
for most laps logged in central park.
It's called the Central Park Loop Challenge.
In one day, he did 16 laps
for just over almost a hundred miles 98.49 miles
in 18 hours, seven minutes and 43 seconds.
He broke the record by five loops.
It's a six mile loop.
Have you ever run that loop in Central Park?
No.
Oh, got to do it man.
I know.
It's one of my favorite runs in the whole world. So great.
I haven't done the whole loop.
I've done a piece of it.
It's got a surprising amount of elevation.
People think oh you just run around.
It's flat.
It's New York City.
But on the North end
as you're kind of rounding the corner
and starting to head sort of South West.
There's a huge hill there.
So over the course of the day,
Robbie ended up bagging.
What was the elevation?
It was something like 4,800 feet of of gain.
And the way this works
the rules are you have
from five minutes after the park opens
at 6:00 AM to five minutes before it closes
at 1:00 AM to run as many loops as possible.
So he absolutely crushed it.
Super cool to see this thing happened.
And I just so happened, coincidentally
to do a photo shoot with the guys from 10,000,
who were sponsoring Robbie in this endeavor.
The guys who documented that came out
and we did a shoot the other day.
So they were telling me all about
like what it was like.
They were behind him on scape.
They're two dudes from San Diego.
And they were on skateboards
and like getting all this cool stuff with them.
How fun.
And they gave me all this behind the scenes
on just how bad-ass the whole thing was
which I thought was really cool.
How about those last five loops
he'd already broken it.
And there must've been a great temptation
to just be like, okay, cool I already got it.
How do you keep going for like another five?
Because he probably had like six hours left.
So he wasn't gonna quit.
Still that kind of stuff it's impressive.
I could see the first victory lap,
but after a while you're like,
should I keep like that last lap?
I don't need it.
I'm already four laps ahead.
I think what was driving him
was to get a hundred miles.
So I think after he got his 16 laps
which was just under a hundred miles,
I think he ran until he eclipsed a hundred.
Fantastic.
Even though it doesn't count.
'Cause it wasn't a whole other full loop.
Anyway, shout out to Robbie
and classic instead of just going home
and putting on the NormaTec boots and chilling,
he ends up joining this guy Hella Sidibe.
What?
In the Navajo Nation.
Hella is in the middle
of doing his own run across America.
I was not familiar
with Hella until Robbie put him on my radar.
But Hella is in the midst of his transcontinental attempt.
And Robbie dropped in on him
in the Navajo Nation and ran some segments
with him which I thought was pretty cool.
Right after this?
Like right after this, basically.
Amazing.
Which is crazy.
So Hella is new on my radar
but I wanted to give him a shout out.
He seems to be a guy
who's just brimming with inspiration.
He seems super cool.
He's @hellahgood9.
H-E-L-L-A-H good and then the number nine on Instagram.
So give him a follow, give him a shout
and put a little wind in his sails.
Love it.
What do you got?
We're gonna talk
about free diving under the ice.
I'll just talk about Alexey Molchanov again.
He dove 80 meters under the ice
in a Siberian Lake called Lake Baikal.
He's an ambassador for this Lake now.
It's one of the largest freshwater lakes in the world.
It goes hundreds of meters deep in different areas.
I think it's like one
of the biggest expanses of freshwater there is
in the world just in terms of volume, maybe the biggest.
And it has freshwater seals
and all sorts of stuff.
And there's villages on the shores
and there's been environmental issues with Lake Baikal.
And so part of the reason he did the dive
was to kind of raise awareness for this great Lake.
So he decided,
it was a couple of years ago.
He's got the deepest dive in the history
of the sport with a monofin 130 meters.
He's got the record for free immersion
which is pulling down the rope at 125 meters.
He pulled down a rope
and he pulled back, no friends at all.
And so he's featured in my book one breath
and I've known him
since I first started covering the sport in 2013.
I've spent time in Russia with him
and with his mother who's since passed.
His mother is Natalia Molchanova.
And she was the greatest in the history of the sport.
And she disappeared in 2015,
free diving on a fun dive.
And overnight, he had to kind
of take control of the entire business
that his mother had built.
And so this story is about this dive
and it's also about that experience for him
and recovering from that.
And one thing I wanted to just kind of bring up
was this idea of deconcentration
that's something that Natalia taught in free diving.
And it's a tool that basically
you try to de concentrate.
You don't focus on the discomforts
of the free dive.
You don't focus on the need to breathe.
You don't focus on the busy-ness at the surface.
You don't even focus
on how beautiful things are down below.
Everything is at a remove.
And that allows you to stay more present and more broad.
And it puts you in more control.
It's kind of like almost a Daoist way
of looking at things.
I'm thinking like this is an approach
that I would like to apply to my life.
Exactly. So deconcentration
as a tool for diving in life.
And that's exactly it.
And if you ask Alexey,
what is the sport of free diving to you?
He says, it's about the mind
and he's a great athlete.
He's got incredibly thick thighs and calves.
He works out, he pumps iron, he does yoga.
He does everything.
And he's an incredibly fit athlete at 34.
But for him to say that
that just shows you what you can do with your mind.
And so I just thought that was cool.
So we'll link to that story.
How many meters did he go?
80 meters in, are we safe in-
39 degrees.
39 degree, 36 degree water, 34 degree water.
And they cut the ice with chainsaws
and the Siberians built an ice sauna,
right next to the hole,
which isn't in the story.
But they actually literally built out
of these bricks of ice nine tons of ice.
They built this sauna
they heated with hot stones
and they cut another hole in the sauna.
And so after he did the dive,
he came back out
and the whole crew came back out
and they like basically had a celebration
in the ice sauna.
And they would like going into the sauna
and then diving into the water
and coming back out.
And that's how they celebrated.
So pretty cool adventure.
I mean, imagine being 80 meters
under the water in 36 degree temp.
The day before he was trying to figure out
what thickness of the wetsuit was.
But just the composure
that you would have to have to not lose it.
He talks about that.
Like when you get down that deep
what you wanna do is kick hard to get back.
'Cause you know how far you have to go but you can't
because it's like an oxygen
savings account in your body.
And all the oxygen is in your blood
and it's gonna burn if you kick harder and harder.
So you have to tell yourself
even though your body's like rebelling
you're getting these contractions
where your body's trying to inflate your lungs,
but you can't
the pressure is heavy
and you can't open your mouth for obvious reasons.
And so you have to kick
and keep your composure, the de concentrate.
And knowing that your mother died doing this.
Knowing that too.
But of course his position is
if he had been there, she would not have.
Because there wasn't a pro
there was not a safety diver at her level
that was there at the time.
So it was a mistake, but pretty amazing.
He had just come from the Maldives
by the way, diving in tropical water.
That's quite a contrast.
He had one day to practice in the Lake.
I would opt for the Maldives.
I'd stick around there.
What's cool about it is the winter is the off season
for most of these professional freedivers.
And a couple of years ago, he decided,
I'm gonna add some winter diving
just something else fun to do
when he's not busy like teaching diving.
His wife just had a baby too.
So he's got a million things going on
but he also has the record for the longest dive
180 something meters in a quarry.
How dark is it when you're 80 meters
down underneath Siberian ice?
I mean, it's dark 80 meters down,
even in the ocean in tropical water,
but in Siberian ice
that's like black ice.
It's basically a midnight.
However, he had a safety diver,
a technical diver, excuse me
at the bottom taking footage.
But also there in case something happened
and another one at 45 meters,
and those guys had cameras and lights.
So there was periods of places where there was lights.
And then the bottom plate itself was illuminated.
And he has a light, like a miner's light like a pen light
that he uses even in deep dives in the ocean.
But it's still dark most of the time.
And then he gets down to the bottom
and it must've been like blinding for him.
It was a three minute dive.
So a sequel to "One Breath", two breaths
one and a half breaths.
Can I use that?
You can use that,
that one's free buddy.
The first one's free.
Hats off Alexey just that's incredible.
All right. Let's do some listener questions.
So the first one I'm gonna read
because it came in via email
all the way from Durban, South Africa.
"Good day, Mr. Roll.
Thank you so much for an amazing powerful podcast.
You truly are an inspiration to me.
I am a pediatrician working in Durban
and I've been running for the last three years now.
As with any sport, I sought out books on running
and came across "Finding Ultra" on audio.
It was tremendous.
And I still listen to it
on the odd day to gain inspiration.
Following the audio book,
I naturally started listening
to every podcast of yours.
Slowly but surely
I started to adjust my diet and lifestyle
with more veggie days than usual.
On one bright more morning on my way to work.
I listened to an episode
which featured Ingrid Newkirk.
And that evening I told my wife
I was stopping meat and dairy.
That was around the 8th of May, 2020.
And since then I've been gaining
all the benefits from the change.
I feel that there were many straws
that were placed under the camel's back
to eventually get me to that point.
But I can assure you
that if it was not for your life story and podcast
I wouldn't be at the most fulfilling time of my life.
I did want to ask a question on roll-on,
but being in South Africa,
I'm not able to leave a voice note.
My question deals
with how to properly address being
with my friends nowadays
because I find it difficult to still hang out
and spend time with them.
I've actually become quite an introvert
and spend more time with matters dealing
with work and family,
which I prefer and enjoy thoroughly.
Is this something you initially experienced?
This is a great question.
Thank you Kumaran Moodley.
Kumaran Moodley.
That's an incredible name.
So a couple observations before I answer the question.
A unbelievable name, two pediatrician spelled P-A-E.
I appreciate that.
Are we sure that wasn't a-
It's like the sort of the Commonwealth spelling.
I'm sorry. I thought that was a typo.
And then thirdly
I like how it was a bright morning
on his way to work when he listened to that podcast.
He's got the writerly gift.
I'm sorry Kumaran on for not saying
it was you who sent in the note.
Kumaran Moodley.
If I'm understanding this correctly,
my sense is that Kumaran's introversion is motivated
at least in part
by a shift in his value system,
which in turn is creating this growing distance
or Valley between what he cares about
and that which his peers value.
And it appears that he feels sheepish about just
being who he is with his friends,
which is not a good place to be.
So I guess my first question is this move towards
becoming more withdrawn
and introverted
because you're afraid of being judged
or because your values have shifted such
that you now feel you have less in common
with those people
that you have been spending time with?
If it's the former again,
not a fun place to be.
So I would encourage you
to do a little internal inventory
on what the downsides are
of just being who you are
and your fully expressed state.
If your friends castigate you
then are they really your friends.
If you feel like, if I tell them
that I'm vegan or whatever else is going on with him
and they're gonna mock him or make fun of him
maybe some of that is just friendly repertoire.
But if there's something more judgemental
or deeper beneath that, then it's a question
of really how valuable are these people to you?
If you feel insecure just being you
then what does that say about you
and the environment that you keep.
Which is a way of saying
I'm not necessarily answering the question
but suggesting things
for you to evaluate or think about.
I think personally, that Kumaran
you should feel super proud of the changes
that you've made for yourself.
Like you're basically making an investment in yourself.
It's agreeing with you,
you feel good about these decisions that you've made
and you should feel comfortable expressing
that without fear of reproach.
So I would do two things.
I would look more deeply
within yourself to examine that insecurity.
If that's the case,
that's motivating the introversion
and try to figure out what is that about?
And if it's your environment
then the good news is you can change your environment
and start surrounding yourself
with more like-minded people.
So it kind of leaves him with two options.
First the choice to maintain your friendships.
And I think it's okay to care
for people who see the world very differently.
And hopefully your friends
can do the same in your direction.
And again, if they're true friends
they should respect your values as you do theirs.
Meanwhile, it's not incumbent upon you to change them
or for them to change you.
So it's about finding a way to gracefully co-exist
with these people that you care about.
The second thing is that
I would encourage you to consider
that perhaps this trepidation around your friends,
and it's difficult to answer this question
'cause I just don't know enough about this dynamic
but it's possible that this dynamic
of fear lives larger in your mind than in reality.
And the only analogy that I can share is that when
I quit drinking, I thought,
oh my God, everyone's gonna know I'm not drinking,
or I'm not gonna be able to hang out with my friends
because if I'm not drinking and they are,
they're not gonna like me,
or I'm not going to be able to participate.
And what I've discovered over time is that,
people are self absorbed.
They don't give a shit.
No one cared.
And if somebody did care,
then I knew like that person
wasn't really my friend to begin with.
At the same time, you can also seek
out new friends who share your values
with whom you feel comfortable being,
who you really are.
Because you can't be a healthy actualized individual
if you feel muted,
whether that sort of self editing is emanating
from within or from without.
So what are you running from?
What are you running towards?
What are you hiding from your friends?
And is that fear real or is that fear imagined?
I think the other thing that I'm getting
the sense I'm getting is that
that there's a loneliness to all of this.
I tweeted one time, you can't break paradigms
and expect to be embraced by the mainstream.
The idea being like
if you're gonna do something
that's kind of outside
of what your social environment approves of
or that is in alignment
with what your peers are doing
that can be a difficult, lonely place.
But it's also an opportunity
for you to invest in your own values
and to work on healthy boundaries around what's okay
and what's not okay for yourself.
And if you can do that
you will experience a boost in self-esteem.
So I think a lot of this does emanate
from some esteem issues.
So maybe look at that as well.
But if you can say, "This is who I am,
and I'm gonna stand on my own two feet
and be that individual
that doesn't mean that you have a megaphone
and you're trying to convince other people
that to share your values
but just to be comfortable in your own skin,
is a very self-affirming, self-actualized,
self-esteem building endeavor for yourself.
He does call it the most fulfilling time of his life.
So maybe there's an aspect
of it that is also very expansive.
So it's like a contraction
and an expansion at the same time.
Like he's feeling connected in ways
that he hadn't before, maybe in the old life.
But in a way that makes him
feel alienated from those friends.
My sense is just that he's changed
and his friends are in a different place.
And he's trying to figure out how to connect
with those people and is not able to do that right now.
That's very good advice, sir.
And so he was asking if you experienced
the only experience that you can relate in that regard.
I didn't really experienced it
with changing my diet so much
but I did experience it when I quit drinking.
For sure.
And a lot what you realize is so much
of it is in your head.
Do you think it helped that,
being an athlete in college
and just knowing people in that space
like having a fitness and a nutrition regimen is normal.
So it wasn't different.
I mean, certainly I had to deal with a lot
of like what you're not eating this
and why you eating that?
And I don't know.
I guess because I had been sober for a long time.
I had some tools for how to deal with all of that.
So it wasn't as challenging or difficult
but being newly sober was very confusing.
And alienating and all of this stuff
that he's sharing I can relate to
from that period of my life.
Nice one.
Well, thanks Kumaran
congrats on all the progress in your own life.
Absolutely and congrats on the name.
So we got Casey from Austin.
Hey, Rich and Adam, this is Casey.
I'm in Austin, Texas.
I was calling to ask.
So I have friends that are always really intrigued
by the plant-based diet I eat
and they always want to know more,
but they never commit.
And I'm wondering,
what do you say to your friends
that are interested in going plant-based.
I'm really interested to hear your answer
and then kind of a followup on that is,
meat eating tends to have like this masculine tendency
like people feel masculine
and it's kind of like one of those things
that you attach to whenever you're like a man.
That's what I find with my friends at least.
I'm wondering how do we make eating
plant-based more masculine?
I don't know if that makes sense
but it's just something
that I've been trying with my head.
Not that I don't feel that way
but more just to make my friends see it
as like less of a weakness, if that makes sense.
So anyways, thanks for taking my call.
Adam great job on the four by four, by 48,
actually hearing that you were gonna do it
kind of inspired me to do it
and had a great experience as well.
Have a good one guys.
Awesome.
Congrats Casey.
On the four by four by 48.
That's cool.
Congrats, Casey.
This is a great question.
It's a pretty common one.
I mean, the first thing I would say, Casey is,
just get out of the business
of being attached to whether your friends do
or do not adopt a plant-based diet.
It's a recipe for frustration.
So I try to kind of in a
if you look at it through the lens of like codependency
like I just try to be,
not invested in what my friends
or other people do or don't do.
And you can still be an advocate
for the things that you believe in
without getting caught up
in the results of that activity.
So I would just say that up front.
The second to that,
the best way to kind of carry the message is
to fan the flames of positive change
and be the example
that you want these guys to see.
So if you wanna dispel the myth
that eating a plant-based diet is somehow feminine.
If you wanna be a masculine example,
then be that person and stand in the light
and live your life accordingly.
And I think that's more resonant
and more impactful than anything
that's gonna come out of your mouth.
If your friends are,
it sounds like some of them are interested.
They kind of dance around this
just have them watch "The Game Changers" documentary.
I mean, that documentary does a pretty good job
of diving into that very issue.
Agreed.
And most dudes find it to be pretty impactful
unless there's a sort of bro tendency
to just switch off the,
and be like, "I can't hear this."
But if they are somewhat receptive
that would be the first resource
that I would direct those guys to.
Again just detach from your expectations.
If they don't commit, it's not your business.
So the idea is that it's about attraction rather
than promotion, which is kind of a sobriety thing.
You wanna be the lighthouse.
I know I keep talking about this.
I keep hammering on this point,
but stand in the light
and be attractor beam.
Attract those like-minded people into your life,
rather than trying to compel other people
to see the world the way that you see it.
And I think you also have to respect the fact
that this masculine meat eater stereotype
is just so crazy embedded in society.
It's very difficult to untangle a knot
that was wound decades ago in that person's life.
Our whole lives we were told
or hammered home the idea
that eating meat is what it means to be a man.
And you can't snap your fingers
and have somebody suddenly not believe that anymore.
When they've been told that a bazillion times
or just society reinforces
that constantly everywhere that you turn.
So I get the dilemma
and I think on a personal level,
it's one of the reasons that I've been
over indexing on the gym
and on strength work lately.
I have this idea, I'm not really racing right now,
so why don't I get jacked?
Why don't I get big and strong?
I turn 55 in October
and I can be a vehicle for dispelling that very myth.
And that's kind of what I've been focused on lately.
That's one of your goals?
I'm gonna play volleyball
in the next Top Gun movie, that's the goal.
Are you gonna be the Tom Skerritt
of the next Top Gun movie?
I might be that old by that time I don't know.
Anyway be the example
that you would like to see,
I guess is the point
that I'm trying to make
and understand that change is difficult
and in the best cases, it's gradual and non-linear.
The good news is it seems
like you have friends
that are kind of interested in what you're doing.
So that's cool.
Like I said, fan the flames of positive change
and put out the welcome mat,
and make them feel excited and energized
by what this adventure might look like
and couch it in the context
of including new things into your diet,
rather than like what you're not eating,
like focus on like,
hey this amazing recipe,
you've never tasted anything so good.
And try to like blow their minds.
You have to make it appealing.
If you wanna appeal to the masculine mind
you gotta make this something that is compelling
for that person to change their mind.
And that's not an easy task.
So in the meantime, live your life well,
that's really the most powerful way to advocate.
I think it's great.
The only thing I would add is
and I can totally understand where you're coming from.
I'm sure in Texas, not to stereotype Texas or anything,
but I'm sure that it's even doubly so,
the call to the meat and with the cultural-
But also it's Austin.
I mean like Austin is pretty vegan-friendly place.
It's vegan in a hippy way,
but it's also the home of Rip Esselstyn,
the King himself, the founder of the whole.
He's the first plant-based athlete
that I'd ever heard of.
Like he's the grand Pappy.
And so you have an opportunity
you could throw a party there's ways of doing it
where you could like
just cater your own event,
where people are trying it for the first time.
But I think what you're saying is perfect.
Just be the lighthouse, be who you are.
I also think it's idea
of like the masculine stuff
that's not for you to worry about
it's interesting, the next question kind of plays in this.
We have friends and then we're going
into talking about masculinity,
which is something I never talk about really.
I never even think about.
It is interesting that the concepts of masculinity
and what that means to young guys
I think it's okay to separate from that.
And not even deal with that.
It's like not on your radar.
But the problem there and why this is so core
to the whole thing is that,
it's the difference between habit change.
Like I'm gonna break this habit
or I'm gonna adopt a new habit and identity change.
This speaks to the core of who I am.
I'm a man and a man behaves in this manner.
I do X, Y, and Z.
And now you're telling me I can't do this thing.
That's a threat to how I see myself.
And so you've got to rewire that whole programming.
So it's much more difficult than just saying,
"Hey maybe don't eat that thing
'cause it's not good for you."
Well, I think game changers
is the perfect place to go.
And if you think about it,
if you're an NBA fan
Chris Paul low key went plant-based
he didn't make a big deal about it.
And he became injury-free
and dominated all of last year
and was one of the best players
in the league again last year
and this year again.
So it works.
And that's why the athletes
are so important in this conversation,
because for a lot of people, particularly dudes,
that's what they pay attention to.
They just wanna see those results.
And so you need those guys out there crushing it.
And there's lots of them.
Lots of them and the funny thing
about Chris Paul was he didn't wanna talk about it.
Not because he was ashamed of it
because he didn't want other people to do it.
He was keeping his competitive edge.
It was his competitive advantage.
All right we've got one more question.
One more.
Hey fellas, my name is Cindy from New Hampshire.
I think you two make a great team
and you're great models
of male vulnerability and connection.
And I think a lot of listeners would benefit
from hearing you to riff on masculinity.
And particularly how you navigated
your own boyhood and early manhood.
And I know Rich you shared a lot
of that in his book and on his show.
But the two of you could inspire guys to dig
into like masculinity expectations,
feeling man enough
the idea of suffered for worthy
and just the whole process
of unhooking from all that throughout your life.
Because even before COVID many boys,
young men, older men
they've been struggling emotionally
and are not comfortable seeking
the help they need before they crack.
So I think men are desperate
to know they're not alone.
And I think you guys could inspire some serious healing.
Thanks so much bye bye.
Cindy, just go into the heart of the whole thing.
That men need help?
Men need a lot of help.
It's a masculinity twofer.
It's a masculinity crisis folks.
Back to back masculinity questions.
Is the problem, too much masculinity?
Well, I mean,
this doesn't even have anything
to do necessarily
with toxic masculinity being
at the far end of that spectrum.
No we're not talking about that.
We're not talking about that,
but what we are talking about is,
again, it goes back to identity
and it seemed that Cindy was interested
in kind of hearing a little bit about how I, you
we navigate our own boyhood and early manhood.
I mean, I'm somebody who never thought
of myself as particularly masculine,
but I did spend most of my boyhood
and early adult life trying
to find my own way into masculinity
by adhering to social norms,
like swimming, academia, law.
And the more that I tried to do that
or double down on that it didn't work
because it was turning a blind eye
to a little self exploration
to figuring out my own identity
rather than trying
to make myself fit into some paradigm.
I was a quiet kid introverted outside of the norm.
I went to a very masculine hyper male high school
and I could never really identify
with what a lot of the other boys
cared about like football.
And I think at that time,
looking back in retrospect
that led me to really question
my own inherent manhood
or relationship to masculinity.
And I think that in turn led to insecurity
and feelings of less than
that something was wrong with me.
And that in turn led me
to withdraw even more and feel ashamed.
And then of course enter alcohol.
Which almost killed me.
So this is how serious these things can become.
And it was only when I was so broken
that I had no other choice,
but to embrace vulnerability.
No other choice than to surrender
to the truth of myself
that I was able to summon the courage
to not only ask for help,
but to receive help
which I think is harder than even
for a lot of people,
much harder than just asking for it.
And in turn be able to heal and accept myself
and mend my insecurities and then access
and grow into a more authentic incarnation of myself.
But I think for most men,
this process is essentially anathema
it's counterintuitive path
that is just off the table
rather than remain stuck in pain.
I think many people are,
what am I trying to say?
I think there are a lot of people
who would rather remain stuck in pain
than appear weak
because showing your truth
is a very terrifying prospect
I think particularly for a lot of men.
And so over the years,
I've worked hard to dispel this myth,
that vulnerability is weakness
that showing emotion is weakness.
And that by leading
with vulnerability and emotion,
it's like this disarming force
that allows and permits others
to kind of meet me in that space.
And I think it's also correct
that most men, young boys
adolescents suffer in silence,
their emotions are in lock down.
They're afraid of being open and honest with anybody.
And over time, if not unlocked,
like this is gonna fester,
it's going to metastasize
and the result is never good.
And that's when we get
into toxic masculinity and violence.
So it's about normalizing the process
of asking and receiving help.
It's about normalizing vulnerability and understanding
that vulnerability and being kind of more
on the surface with your emotions
is not mutually exclusive from masculinity.
You can love football,
you can love MMA and cars and guns
or whatever we associate with conventional norms
that surround our definition of what is
and what isn't masculine
and be open honest, vulnerable,
caring, all of those things.
And inquisitive.
I think that you demonstrate that.
I think that's part of the appeal to David Goggins
the major part of it, and Joe Rogan as well,
kind of like this masculine version
of being open inquisitive
and vulnerable about life basically.
I think the podcast host
that exemplifies it perhaps better
than anybody is Dax Shepard,
because he's very much like a dudes dude.
He likes to race cars
and he wears like cutoff shirts
and he's a blue collar guy
from Michigan and like chews tobacco.
And he's a dudes dude
but he's also somebody
who wears his emotions on his sleeve
and he's very vulnerable.
And he tells his friends, he loves them.
He does all this stuff
that is sort of countered
to what you think like a dudes dude would do.
And I think it's part
of why his message is so powerful and impactful
and why I think he's such a good podcast host.
But it's that like combination,
like I'm not a dudes dude in the way
that Dax is but I still would characterize myself
as having a certain kind of masculinity
that through a lot of internal work
is not under threat
because I tell you, Adam, I love you.
You know what I mean?
Thank you. I love you too.
Yes, we'll make out afterwards.
I agree.
I mean, my story,
I'm gonna drop a little bomb here
but we don't have to belabor it too much,
but I grew up
I was sexually abused at seven years old.
I didn't know that.
And then grew up
and went through puberty late
and was really small for my age most of my life,
even though I was interested in sports
and was pretty good.
I had to question myself along the way
and I kind of like stuffed down the abuse
for a long time.
I didn't tell anybody.
And then I didn't really come up
and address it until what was it?
Like 99, 2000 I think right around there.
So I would be 28 around then,
is when I first started to deal with it.
And at first it was hard.
Guru Singh helped me through it at the beginning.
And I went through a process of therapy through him,
but not through traditional means
like going to a psychotherapist.
I went to a yoga teacher
who happens to be a great therapist also,
but he's not traditional.
And at the same time kind of like what's helped me.
Isn't been attaching to, I've never felt
like I needed to be some macho dude.
That's never been my thing 'cause I never was.
'Cause I was always kind of smaller
and felt smaller even when I grew.
And so I just never felt the need to do it.
I never wanted to be in that mode
and was never attracted to it.
But at the same time,
I'll bro out just like anybody else.
So I understand that like having a group
of guy friends can be empowering to young guys
and having some people you're close to you can be.
And so that was never a problem for me either.
So I've kind of
as riding this line of having the secret
and broing out and never really addressing it.
What's helped me most of all
has been kind of discovering things like yoga
which is kind of a more feminine practice
and Daoism which is a book I read
Taoism Ching from cover to cover.
Basically I read a verse,
maybe multiple days in a row,
then I'll start again at the beginning
and I'll switch translations.
And that is again, kind of looking
at the universe not in duality but in oneness.
I think my advice would be
or things I like to tell people is,
let's not try to look at things in duality.
Let's look at things as a unity
that we're a part of everything all the time.
And I'm not one of those people that's like
against gender constructs in any way shape or form.
I just think it's beyond gender.
It's a conversation beyond gender.
It's a connection beyond the individual.
It's an expansion that we are everything all the time.
And when you think of it, that way the deconcentration
of the small thing and get bigger.
Sometimes I feel like the luckiest man in the world.
I mean, well thank you for sharing that story.
I didn't know that about you.
Thanks.
That's pretty heavy.
We can talk more about that.
We can unpack that.
We will definitely unpack a little bit more of that.
I think that I agree with you on all of that,
but I also think that some of what you're talking
about is a bit esoteric.
Like in the context of like a young male,
who's struggling with his relationship to masculinity
and his peer group, the only way to motivate
that young individual to engage
with his interior emotional life in a healthy way.
If he's one of these people
that seems shut down in that regard,
is to model healthy behavior
in that guy's environment.
So putting a strong male in proximity to that person
who is an example of how to kind of do this
in a healthy way, I think is really the lever
that moves the needle.
So whether it's somebody in the community
or a relative or a coach or a teacher,
or somebody on YouTube
or a podcast host or something like that,
that that young person can connect with
and start to think a little bit differently about
how he's relating to himself
and his direct environment
I think is a really powerful thing.
That would be the advice that I would give.
Having mentors is key.
And also holding yourself accountable
and working on yourself.
If you say you're gonna do something, go do it.
Like these kinds of things can make you feel.
And it's probably just about growing up in general
but as a young man,
it can make you feel more of a man.
If you know you can rely
on yourself to do what you say you're gonna do.
You can feel more empowered as a man.
But the trick is you can do that
and still be repressing all of emotions.
That's true.
You know what I mean?
So it's about having
a healthy relationship with those emotions.
Like what is the outlet for that?
So that later on in life
it doesn't manifest in a toxic manner.
What would you say a good outlet
would be finding therapy or doing?
Well, I mean, it depends on the individual
but that's why I think just having healthy males
that model healthy behavior
in the orbit of that young person
will be the most powerful
because it will demonstrate to that person like,
hey it's okay for me to like
talk about my feelings or it's safe.
I'm not gonna get chastised or ridiculed
because I have this weird emotion
and I'm afraid to share it with anybody.
Good points.
You model healthy behavior Rich Roll.
Not all the time.
I lose my shit every once in a while. Trust me.
You do?
All right. Well, we've been going
for like two and a half hours.
So we're gonna wrap this thing up.
Thank you for sticking around
if people are listening still.
Thanks for listening to us.
The whole journey today.
And if you didn't listen
to the last bit, just forget, I mentioned it.
Do you feel like you just had a catharsis?
Yeah, I feel like you're my Oprah.
I don't know about that.
That makes me nervous.
You did disclose something pretty heavy there though.
I did, but it's okay.
I once wrote a novel where it was part of it.
And so I was prepared to disclose it then
of course nobody bought it
so I could have taken it back.
Well, you did it in a way
that felt very comfortable to you.
So clearly you've done enough work around it
that it's not like causing you distress.
No, thank you.
Appreciate it.
Good for you man.
Thanks.
Cool, well until next time,
we'll be back in two weeks.
Follow Adam @adamskolnick.
I'm of course at @richroll.
If you want your question considered for the show
leave us a message at (424) 235-4626.
Check out the show notes
on the episodePage@richroll.com.
We'll have links up to everything we talked about today.
Again, hit that subscribe button on YouTube, Apple, Spotify.
We recently created a clips channel on YouTube.
We've gotta start uploading more clips there we're behind
but we got big plans for that channel.
You can find it by searching
Rich Roll podcast clips on YouTube,
or we'll link it up in the show notes as well.
Smash that button.
Smash it.
Appreciate you guys.
Love you see you back here
in a couple of days
with another awesome episode.
And Adam and I will be back of course in two weeks.
So until then peace plants.
Namaste.